certainly skewed that way i mean i don't
want to start gender warfare because
frankly i'd give money to a goat if i
get a return but the truth is if you
look at my portfolio over nine years and
that's a long time in small private
companies as a result of shark tank and
all the auxiliary companies i get to see
because of the shark tank platform not
some of my returns all of my returns
have come from the runs ones run by
women so
first point here i forgot to john he
didn't say some of his returns he said
all of his returns are coming from
female-led companies
um
for perspective
i don't know what the exact number is
but from my experience in um
entrepreneurs or in toronto there was
145 members in the chapter in toronto to
qualify you had to be the founder of the
business and be doing at least a million
dollars a year in sales
i was in two forums uh during that time
and um i've had females in the forum
there's usually about nine to ten people
perform and there's usually one to two
females per group so i'd say it's it's
probably fair to say that somewhere
between 10 and 10 and 15
maybe as high as 20 depending on the uh
region are female-led companies um
i don't know any of them personally that
had gone bankrupt or had any strong
financial issues but they structure
themselves in an interesting way which i
have a feeling we're going to get from
o'leary right here let's let's hear them
out we're owned by women and i speculate
it's for two reasons number one is
they're extremely strong at time
management skills that old adage if you
want something done give it to a busy
mother it turns out to be true in
companies that are generally doing in my
case between five and five hundred
million i've never heard that um if you
want something done give it to a busy
mother
that's new sales so small numbers
generally the average size is 20
employees they're extremely strong at
allocating the time skills of those
people but secondly and this is the most
fascinating one to me
when i look at the goals that are met on
a quarterly basis particularly in
revenue on the companies run by women
they achieve those goals 90 percent of
the time versus 65 percent of the time
on the run the ones that i own okay so
one of the points he's making here is
that when women set revenue goals which
you're gonna get from a guy like o'leary
he's gonna he's gonna invest his money
you're gonna take his capital you're
gonna
you know deploy it for whatever you need
whether it's hiring equipment expansion
whatever it happens to be marketing
um and then he's gonna ask you okay well
what are your revenue goals like last
year you did
five mill in sales you know what do you
expect to do in the next 12 months and
what he's saying here is that women hit
the revenue goals 90 percent of the time
he says the mail led companies only hit
the revenue goals 65 percent of the time
let's see if he tells us why that is run
by men and we've basically got about 44
companies in this portfolio and a long
period of time sorry so it was 44
companies over nine years i thought it
was 40 but it's 44 companies well over
seven years so by setting goals that are
achievable here's my theory you get less
staff turnover morale stays higher and
when you're a company with only 15 or 20
people
so he's saying that when these
female-led companies set goals that are
more reasonable
and they achieve them staff morale
remains higher
um
i'm not going to disagree with it but
i'm not going to vehemently agree with
it either i don't know that that's it
um
let's take a listen to the rest of this
clip and go to the next one to see if
there's something there and you lose the
head sales person or the person
responsible for logistics it's extremely
disruptive and perhaps that's why these
women-led companies are doing a better
job setting goals that are achievable
and allocating time skills or time
management in a much more effective way
and as a result now generally in new
deals i tell the guys that are running
o'leary ventures skewed towards the
women led deals we're just making all
right so
that's interesting um now
he didn't mention it here in this sound
bite let's see if we can get it off uh
is this one over here what men can learn
from female ceos let's switch over
to the next one
because one of the things i heard in the
other podcast that i was listening to
um
was this what men can learn from women
ceos this is it over here
chrome tab
and share audio boom okay so
let's just pull that out for a sec um
so one of the things he didn't mention
in that soundbite from that news
interview was that men set higher goals
than women so
women aren't achieving the same revenue
goals that men are setting they're
achieving
the revenue goals 90 percent of the time
as they set them
what we know about the difference
between men and women
is that men will generally more often
not play to win and women will generally
more often than not play not to lose
similar sort of sounding thing but
they're not the same
of all the companies and all the
entrepreneurs that i know that have
had hyper growth like massive growth in
fact um when profit magazine was given
out the awards uh for the fastest
growing companies in canada for the
profit 50 profit 100 profit 200
um there's some female-led companies
that i met at those um awards and the
subsequent weekend retreats but um none
of them were in the top i'm going to say
10 or 15 for sure um i didn't or or i
can't blatantly
recall them so a lot of the fastest
growing companies with the highest
percentage of growth
um
seem still to be run by men because high
testosterone greater risks
higher levels of ambition obviously and
this isn't to disparage women or to say
you know men are better or anything like
these like this is just facts right um
men are generally like there's a there's
a reason why more men ride motorcycles
right
men like taking risks um women not so
much they generally play not to lose so
he didn't hit on it here but he did hit
on in the other podcast and he said men
are setting much higher goals than women
and they're not hitting them women are
setting goals that they hit generally
speaking because they're lower because
again they play not to lose rather than
play to win so
that's the reasoning behind it he didn't
mention it there in that clip let's just
pull up this element over here and see
what we got on uh the title of this one
says
uh kevin o'leary what men can learn from
women's ceos
um
oh wait hold on a second yeah that's it
okay so let's hit uh replay it's passing
you both mentioned nurturing here for a
second i mean kevin traditionally there
are a lot of people that believe that
women were going to be too soft you know
they're all about sort of the heart
aspect when it comes to the head when it
comes to having to make uh difficult
business decisions that they're not able
to do it do you feel like we're still
sort of stuck in that mindset a little
bit and how do you feel like we're going
to bring some of the fuddy-duddies uh
into the 21st century i i think what's
happening here
and we're just seeing some anecdotal
evidence of it as we talk to these women
is they tend to set goals that are
achievable that and therefore they have
less risk in their businesses because
okay he touched on it there women's set
he's calling them achievable goals right
there's
there's something called a b hag i don't
know if you guys have heard about this
before but bhag's an acronym for big
hairy audacious goal
a b hag is generally something that a
company usually a startup with a very
small staff they'll plaster it on the
wall or they'll or they'll come up with
these b hags which are like
pretty pretty crazy things like i
remember we had some bee hags on this
can you imagine wall so we have this
wall in our office said can you imagine
it would say things like um you know
getting a banner advertisement on the
highway uh being featured on uh
breakfast television morning news uh
which we managed to get actually most of
these um
now that i'm reflecting back on it but
you generally set these like
higher numbers it's like okay
we're looking for 75 percent growth this
year which isn't normal i mean in a
startup company it's reasonably normal
but an older company not so much like
very old companies gm you know ford
chrysler xerox you know stuff like that
they don't grow very fast maybe a few
percent per year but they generally are
highly profitable they throw off
dividends and they're great for
investors so you know a lot of those
blue chips you know have themselves
sorted but
where o'leary is making this money is
he's making his money off these startups
that are growing and hitting goals so
he's saying right here women set lower
goals and they hit them they
i'm gonna use the word lower he's saying
achievable but they're not setting goals
as audacious as you know the men seem to
be setting
they set goals that actually they can
make because they just have an intuitive
feeling that it's within reach and they
deliver so into intuitive feelings right
men don't have intuitive feelings only
women have intuition one of the biggest
challenges if you have a lot of bravado
and perhaps too much testosterone you
set goals for employees you can never
make you want to feel rah-rah you want
to feel good about setting something in
sales for example that you're never
going to get and then ultimately when
it's clear you're not going to get there
you start to take an ordinant risk to
try and make up for the gap that's what
i think is happening in some of the
businesses run by men and i'm listen i'm
kind of agnostic to this i don't pick
size i'm just saying the results for me
as measuring the only thing that matters
in business cash flow is on the side of
women i'm just getting more capital back
they've de-risked my business that way
and i think we could all learn from
whatever they're doing and apply it to
everybody so that means so
it sounded like from the prior
interview that that he was talking about
instructing his people during due
diligence to really spend a lot more
time on the female lead companies
because in the past they've generated
better returns for him or the source of
his returns
that's interesting right because imagine
the roles were flipped
and
you know somebody like him or someone
else on shark tank you know said
something like well i get better returns
for men so i'm only going to invest in
men essentially what he was saying in
the other clip
but i mean you couldn't get away with
that language today especially on
mainstream media you know tv shows like
shark tank um they would try to cancel
his ass right away
and could take you know sort of a
playbook from them and say why don't i
do the same thing because at the end of
the day business is about risk you put
money out you determine what's the
probability of getting it back but not
just your original capital you need to
get a return and so i anticipated all of
these businesses that we're talking to
these women in wicked cupcakes honey
fund you know
they're really good that's the other
thing too like the companies that women
run they run in areas of um
like their expertise it's almost like
their hobbies for a lot of them like um
just just kind of thinking back to my eo
day so
there was a girl that ran a clothing
company for fluffy white dogs
um
and she sourced all of her clothing from
china she was chinese so she would go to
the factories order the stuff you know
and then sell it in north america done
very well but it but you know she had
fluffy white dogs it was something like
you know she knew like the back of her
hand um i think one of the mistakes that
i see a lot of guys make um and i see it
in the school of entrepreneurship now
too because um you know i've gone
through the first batch of um students
and
a lot of guys aren't picking things that
they're totally passionate about one of
the things i've noticed about women is
like there's just one other check that
was uh totally stoked about electric
bicycles um you know sourced a
manufacturer provider in china white
label branded it you know started
selling it in north america did really
well because you know huge huge passion
for another check i knew that did um
uh non-profit
swag
did really well with that another chick
i knew that got into um
how do you define it it was it it was a
um
social and and sports lead because that
was her thing you know when she was in
university right so
i mean you know there's that to be said
it i see a lot of guys try to start up
things just to make money and or you
know because it's because it's popular
or it's trendy or it's like oh i heard
you know if i do this then i can make a
lot of money and it's like you know
the the um you know the copyrighting
guys the um uh you know the guys that do
like the trinkets and uh
um shopify store or amazon you know
deployment for men's jewelry or whatever
it happens to be um
i have noticed that women do move into
uh businesses that they know like the
back of their hand bottle breacher at
delivering
back a plan for a higher return that's
what matters we're not talking about
these women being as good as men we're
talking about them being better than men
as measured by return of capital that's
what i'm talking about oh no
again imagine the tables were turned
and he said something
180 degrees opposite to that men are
doing what better than women this isn't
about equality this is about supremacy
i'm sorry and and i think we should all
be looking at this and saying what do
these women do how do they do it and why
shouldn't everybody else do the same
thing i want these kind of returns from
all of my deals not just ones run by
women wanted from all of them and so i'm
telling guys now that approached me
about business saying look look at the
attributes of this deal look at how it's
structured look at the returns i've made
on wicked good cupcakes even bottle
breacher which is a brand new deal for
me is just killing it and already
wicked good cupcakes is one of the
companies he invested let me just check
this out
pops up right away as soon as you start
typing into google wiki good cupcakes
nationwide cupcake delivery yeah like
i've seen this a lot man cupcake stores
um
oh yeah these are the ones that are in
the jars these are like the jarred
cupcakes
anyway let's let's keep playing this
through
here we're talking about expanding honey
funds to plum funds which is a brand new
brand new platform this is all growth
all of this is growth so whatever
they're doing is working and i think
it's hard to say exactly what it is but
the evidence is that they're very good
at managing time number one they're
reducing their risk and their volatility
by setting goals that their teams can
achieve i think there's a lot to be said
for that and lastly they've chosen
markets intuitively that they can grow
in so you know i mentioned that earlier
right they you know they choose markets
like they know like the back of their
hand well that these are three evidences
that anybody looking at these from a
petri dish would say that's what they've
done right and i think that's the way
i'm going to measure as i go in to start
filming season seven in a couple of
weeks for shark tank we have a hundred
thousand applications wow i'm going to
try and find more businesses like these
businesses because they've already got a
all right well he's giving away the
secret sauce to his peers on the show um
i like kevin o'leary um
he wrote a book a few years ago and um
he also tried to um
i guess apply or run for the
conservative party of canada you know
the federal party to uh you know become
the next prime minister but um you know
they they uh
they didn't want him in
let's just say that so you know he stuck
to tv and investing money which is
probably a better deal for him anyway
far but far better deal but um i think
he's a great guy i've met him personally
actually um if if you've seen my school
of entrepreneurship landing page uh
there's a picture of me and him uh
standing together at eo whistler um he's
not a tall man he's he's a little
vertically challenged but
super smart well-spoken
uh smart businessman you know success
leaves leaves clues so i always try to
pay attention to and listen to podcasts
or conversations with people that offer
opinions on topics that i'm interested
in so when i saw the thing about female
entrepreneurs doing better than his mail
investments i thought okay you know both
of those things are right in my
wheelhouse let's let's have a
conversation hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged dot com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you